[music playing]
Oh, what's it doing?
It's still pointing
in the right direction?
It's drifting towards us.
NARRATOR: Paul is
flying the climate
team's $80,000 drone system.
And it's fighting so much
wind, it just can't handle it.
NARRATOR: And the winds are
gusting to 70 miles per hour.
Maintain heading.
I'll tell you when to turn.
Thank you.
That's good.
Do a right-hand turn in
three, two, one-- now.
[whirring]
How's that?
That's good.
Maintain heading.
That's easier said than done
when it's beyond 54 knots.
You're doing good.
We're seeing
60-knot average wind
speeds, which is very high.
The most I've ever flown
in is about 50 knots.
Left-hand turn a bit.
Keep going.
But yeah, there's
obviously more
pressure to make the most of
the remaining time we've got.
It's gonna move south a bit.
And if we don't
fly, they're going
to be missing a large
component of the data
that they planned on getting.
A right-hand turn again
in three, two, one.
[whirring]
I mean, it just
can't handle it.
It's too much wind for it.
We do a couple of more,
and then we call it off.
[music playing]
Your left hand,
adjustment a little bit.
That's it?
Because it's struggling
into that wind,
it's using battery up faster.
We might have to land.
Keep going-- almost there.
Right-hand turn, now.
A low battery-- now
I've got a battery alert.
I'm coming home.
OK.
That's good.
NARRATOR: The team has a
complete data set from higher
altitude, but they
still need to get
the drone back in one piece.
We've got to figure out
where we're going to land.
So this dry, dusty sand
gets into the motor,
so we're going to try and
land on this wet sand.
Of course, the danger with
that is there's a river.
So if we overshoot our landing,
we end up in the drink.
That would be bad.
The gear is not waterproof.
You ready?
Retract the probe
please, [inaudible].
OK, the probe
should be retracted.
OK, good.
[MUSIC PLAYING AND A WHINING
SOUNDS]
[cheering]
Oh, you like hopped the river.
How cool was that?
Outstanding.
So from the angle I
was standing back there,
there's a bit of terrain.
You can see the skid
mark-- bounce, jump.